if you are a member of congress and
you're a democrat like this has been
your opportunity to get big things done
and you see the writing on the wall
you're like even if i get reelected i'm
going to be here in the minority party
and it's going to suck
um so am i really going to sign up for
that um the the second factor is that
right now the climate in congress is
very very
negative and uh spiteful um where
someone told me that
the capital or the halls of congress
used to be like a shopping mall um even
at like 6 7 p.m because everyone's just
like going around well there's like a
lot of energy a lot of life you like
walking around staffs like um uh you
know doing work
now they they say all the doors are
closed and it's like uh
you know like a ghost mall or uh like
the vibe is really negative people are
just trying to get out of there staff
are very demoralized um uh part of this
was the january sixth insurrection where
uh like it changed the energy made
people not feel safe
and that there have been a ton of
uh death threats to various members of
congress
much more so than at earlier points
um so if you were a democratic member of
congress you're like wait why am i like
coming back for this stuff what's my
upside down yeah what what's my upside
so you're seeing a bunch of people
retire will that hurt democrats chances
of you know like limiting their losses
yes it will because you know you'd much
rather have an experienced incumbent
with lots of money running in a seat
rather than someone new yeah so the
prospects of republicans taking the
house next year i think everyone
recognizes are very very high
[Music]
this week on forward build back better
uh is it
dead is it coming back is it on life
support we give our read here
plus omicron why you should probably
expect to get it at some point
unfortunately and why the new spider-man
movie
is the future that we want this week on
forward
and we're back zach is in his parents
crafts room with a mic in his face
looking like he's reporting the like uh
weather from indoors welcome zach i
guess you're hoping for the holidays
happy holidays andrew don't um do not
assume
that i grew up in a house big enough
that warranted a craft room it's a bit
of an over investment into the crafts
uh
as a hobby i think from my mother's side
of things but i'm in the craft room
i could have been in our studio talking
to an empty chair we could have done
like a reenactment of the rnc or
something
but instead
instead we are here to talk about a few
big topics number one is build back
better
the incredible drama out of dc
really
such a mess
but i will say that it looks like it's
been somewhat
uh tamped down already and what should
have been an internal conversation
just happened to have been made public
so we can rehash the drama that if
people haven't heard about it uh but
zach thoughts dude what a mess man so
high level guys build back better has
not passed yet and joe manchin senator
from west virginia has said
he's out and it was very public
and my original thought andrew was
here we are with a washington dc food
fight
while the country is burning and so you
had mansion
saying
joe biden your team has pissed me off
and this bill isn't gonna work and then
the white house team
made a statement that just threw the guy
under the bus and said he was awful
that's my high level thought i think we
should dive in andrew
i think
my question for you
i think you
essentially called this no you said like
you're gonna have it's gonna get worse
where it gets better i think i don't
know i don't know if that was your exact
quote but you were kind of pessimistic
on this am i right well i was
pessimistic that it was going to get
done by your end which made me very very
upset because uh you have
62 million americans who are benefiting
from the enhanced child tax credit and
if it gets delayed past year end and
they're gonna miss a payment at this
point
if we miss a payment and then they come
back in february that would be the
absolute best case but i was dubious
that it was going to be passed by year
end just when the calendar from the
magnitude of it
from the public statements and so here's
the the way the drama seems to have
unfolded where
uh
they were still apart
and then the biden white house came out
with a statement saying hey it's not
going to happen and it's joe manchin's
fault and then mansion apparently got
really really pissed off by this and and
then
a few days later went on fox news and
was like hey i'm out
and the white house tried to call him
before he went on air and he didn't take
that call
he then did an interview uh the next day
and
uh well actually you're right that the
biden white house then released a
statement essentially accusing him of
dishonesty um saying hey you know he'd
been on board with this a few days later
and hopefully he changes his mind again
it just made it seem like oh like joe
manchin is like
um flip-flopping
and then mansion the next day gets
interviewed and says that the white
house is staff driven and this is the
staff and they know what they did and so
uh manchin did something very very
generous which is he didn't trash joe
biden he trashed his staff which then
actually gives you a bit of a path back
and joe biden and joe manchin had a call
and these guys have known each other for
decades and so apparently cooler heads
may be
prevailing and joe manchin may come back
in january ready to deal which by the
way was where everything was
you know like a week ago it's like like
things are kind of slow walking but
everyone thought that there was a deal
to be made and and so it seems like this
is just
miscommunication playing out for all to
see
um but a couple of things you can
lay at the white house's feet and when
you say white house i guess in this case
it's the staff it's like number one
uh name checking joe manchin as the
cause for it not passing uh by year end
uh was probably the wrong move because
it seems to have just pissed joe manchin
off and like resulted in egg in
everyone's face and number two when he
goes and announces that he's out uh
accusing him of dishonesty like you know
doesn't seem productive uh even if you
feel that or believe that because the
math is still the math you need 50
senators to pass this thing uh or some
version of it uh you've been building up
to it for months and months
uh and so
you can look at this and say that the
the white house uh misjudged um and
miscommunicated uh
where mansion's concerned and hopefully
you know like the harm isn't anything
people can't walk back from so it's
unique for him because he does
his state is what plus 30
40 points for trump right yeah so that's
39 trump
he cannot he doesn't have to play team
dem he's in a rare position we've talked
about this before his statement
essentially said if he can't explain it
back home he can't vote for it um he
basically said it was too expensive
um citing rising debt uh inflation and
because of the um
rising threats geopolitically
specifically russia and china he called
out we won't be if we have massive debt
we won't be able to fight back or defend
ourselves
and then he also mentioned i think
things that hit close to home in west
virginia
issues with the energy portions of
buildback better where
it would risk the reliability of our
electric grid and increase our
dependence on foreign supply chains
talked about what happened both in both
texas and california over the past two
years and that if we accelerate too fast
that's what happens whether he's right
or not not sure and then the white house
said
um
they were really strong in their punch
back on the
uh
expenditure side whether they're
accurate or not they said the cbo the
congressional budget office um
talked about that there's no inflation
for this bill in the law in the short
term and it reduces inflationary
pressures in the long term
it lowers the cost of a bunch of things
um it they claim that that build back
better is the most fiscally responsible
major bill that congress has considered
in years and reduces the deficit in the
long run that's a direct quote um
and so they punched back pretty hard on
the budget side of things but they did
not punch very bad part they did not
punch hard
or very hard back on the
climate change piece all they said was
that he's wrong
and that build back better will produce
a job-creating clean energy future for
this country including west virginia
that was our only statement on it um so
i don't know if your thoughts were if
you've looked into the climate side of
build back better or if you think this
is just food fighting and hand waving
and none of this matters in terms of
getting it done or do these specifics
actually matter in your opinion well
west virginia is
its own place uh it's highly coal
dependent in terms of the economy
it has the sixth highest poverty rate in
the country
uh but it is trump plus 39. so
uh one of the dynamics here is that joe
manchin has said very openly it's like
hey you want me to leave the democratic
party i'll leave
and then the democrats immediately are
like no no no like that's not what we
mean
um and the republicans have very openly
said hey joe join us
we would love it
so
so one of the the
uh facts i saw that i i found
interesting and that this is from
uh the people's basics which is um
uh like a
friendly podcast
um and so they said look uh five percent
of democrats are not for a build back
better and so expect so if you have a
couple of senators who aren't for it
that actually match it up checking out
like that if you have 50 senators uh two
senators maybe aren't
yeah it's like that that foreign
sense but apparently about 34 of
republicans are for buildback better
and uh zero republicans are for it and
so like that's the the mismatch
and this is the argument i would make is
that and people
are looking up saying oh it's uh you
know that like this drama is upsetting
uh you know the the fact that the
democrats
don't have unanimity on this stuff
should not be surprising though because
you have a very very big tent party
that's stretching all the way from joe
manchin to you know the other extreme
uh camilla jayapal i guess would embody
the the opposite extreme
um and so you have to look at the other
side and say
again like that the problem is
polarization
it's the lack of bipartisanship it's the
fact that zero republicans are willing
to be for any aspect of this which then
puts the democrats in this very tenuous
position where they're trying to to do
it through reconciliation can't lose a
single vote
and the the proposal that i sent out
there a lot of other people sent out
there too is like look if you just vote
on the child tax credit
you might get
10 republican senators who are for it
you know i i can say very confidently
mitt romney's for it so that gets you
like 51 and then you know like there are
a bunch of others that are at least uh
willing to contemplate it um and so the
problem now is that
you you have a two-party system that
requires
uh someone to have a real majority to
legislate because
you know the other party won't help you
at all um
and and then you wind up with joe
manchin having this much clout and power
and then if west virginia has a
particular take on an issue let's say
climate change
that that becomes
um uh the game changer yeah deal breaker
in this case though i do think that joe
manchin's coming back in january and
that there's still going to be a deal to
be done you know why because no one has
a choice like you know like like the the
entire team dem and the binding
administration's been building up to
this for
like not eons but like you know five six
months um so they can't just go to zero
uh joe manchin is still a dem he his uh
constituents still do have problems
there are a lot of parts of this bill
that he's already
said he's open for
uh you know even his self-reporting is
like look he's gained for 1.5 trillion
uh you know though he wants it to be
paid for
and the congressional budget office here
here's the way they do things is like
they think that if you have a new
program then the new program sticks
around which by the way is correct
the way the dc bill measures it is like
hey we just have this thing for one year
five years uh not even five years man
one year so you know so so if you look
at it it legitimately is like hey this
thing's 10 times more expensive than you
say it's going to be and
the cbo is generally accurate on that
and everyone knows it
[Music]
my question andrew is when you were
running for mayor new york you talked
about when you're running a budget like
this
if you're going to spend
you have to spend on things that
generally grow the pie
um you want to for sure or yeah in
theory right so like and it's a they're
tough decisions i remember one of the
best ones you had talked about like okay
in theory and from a human level is
hiring
a hundred thousand social workers a good
idea like yeah that's gonna make a lot
of people like healthier stronger and
whole they're gonna do a lot of
wholesome work but are they going to
grow the economy so that i have more
budget to pay for them two three ten
years from now probably not given the
nature of their work
and so
investing at least in the beginning with
stuff like this when you're in a deficit
to things that are going to grow the
economy grow the pie
and make it bigger for next time so that
you can pay for those social workers
well for the record using that as an
example i actually would i think the
social workers are a good investment but
continue okay but whatever it was right
um
yeah yeah but there's something else um
well there's certain things that in um
where they're helping people but they're
helping like stop bleeding as opposed to
growing right so i'm getting um
are there measures in buildback better
that you think grow the pie or you think
is it the same logic
at the federal level i don't know your
thoughts are there in terms of
making this uh in terms of the economic
stimulus pieces of this yeah i stand up
and down and just like you know champion
the child tax credit because to me
that's a pie grower for sure it's like
you put money into the hands of
families that are close to the water
line and then their their kids are
healthier
better able to learn
um you know have
bet school supplies
less stress in the household um so and
they're going to spend every single
dollar
where
the freaking grocery store
day care centers
uh small businesses locally like you
name it like that that money is going to
go it's probably going to get spent more
than once
and so you're alleviating poverty you're
improving people's lives uh and one of
the things about the example you said
with the social workers is that when
people fail it's very very expensive
right you know like if a family
ends up on the street incredibly
expensive use the new york example it's
like a homeless person in new york if
they wind up in the sheltering system
uh is
costing
something absurd like you know 72
thousand dollars uh uh uh a year so you
look at it and be like wait a minute you
just like pay for someone's rent on that
and it's like oh you theoretically could
um because we have very very expensive
dysfunctional systems
so if there is uh
um something i'm pumped about it is the
child tax credit uh there are other
elements of the the
the mega bill that you know like i'm
warm to
um but none of them like uh delivers a
bang for the buck like the child tax
credit i like the prescription drug
oh yeah
they can negotiate for lower
prescription drug prices i mean that
that thing is approved by something like
75 percent of americans because it's
obvious
um i you know i i didn't think that had
survived zach um you know that that's in
there probably he's trying to i mean who
knows i know the medical obviously
managed to kill that thing i mean i'm
curious your prediction here do we end
up with like a watered-down version of
build back the original buildback better
which was so all-encompassing and we're
to get like half measures on all of
these or do we end up with like one or
two big things
that will work and a bunch of other you
know less important or smaller
um let's call it nonsense
i think we wind up with a watered-down
buildback better uh you know i i like
the the dems don't have a choice but to
try and keep pushing it through
um i it's you know it seems like joe
manchin wants to do a deal
um and that those are the main players
right now uh i i i will say though that
when this stuff came out
it made me very sad and i think it
should make everyone very sad is that
um you have
such clear dysfunction out of dc
um
and it turns out uh just like real
mismanagement real
uh just miscommunication from people who
should be on the same team and we've had
long-standing working relationships the
whole thing's just sad um and it's
particularly sad for the again tens of
millions of americans who were
hoping that they'd get a check in
january uh like they have the last
number of months so i've been sad really
the last number of days even though now
it looks like they're going to come back
to the table maybe nothing has changed
you will wind up with some kind of
watered-down version of this thing i
think
um all of that said
apparently it gets harder and harder to
pass a bill in
the next
term or not not the legislative term um
where when they come back from the
holidays because now it's election year
time things get harder
um apparently um but i think they'll
pass some watered-down version in part
because they've been baking this thing
for so long and manchin has been on the
record saying he'd approve something at
around like one and a half trillion
would have been better to say okay i'm
going to pass 10 bills one's a child tax
credit one's universal pre-k one's a
negotiation for prescription drugs like
get everybody on the record on each one
and let people make their own
compromises
that way instead of putting it all into
one kind of big like comeback plan
because it's because of this
reconciliation process weirdness man
like they had to smash it all together
because they're trying to pass it along
narrow party lines on a technicality
to get around the filibuster yeah
okay i don't fully understand not
claiming to be a dc expert just a
outsider talking to you with an opinion
yeah so that there's so the there's a a
narrow way that you can
pass bills uh just along like a simple
majority so in this case it's like 50.1
votes because they get accountable as
the tiebreaker um
and
uh there are certain things you're not
allowed to do like a reconciliation what
they do is they say it's like hey all of
this is budgetary
uh
there's like a giant game being played
um it's one reason why certain things
that they want to touch like immigration
reform they're actually rules saying no
no you can't do that through this
process
got it so that's why they need all 50
and that they had to do it this way it's
really a mess
you know in a way like that there so
there is like an argument to be made um
that
you know like democrats are trying to
govern as if they have a more durable
majority than they have um which i'm
which i don't hate in the sense it's
like yeah shoot your shot like go for it
you know but
[Laughter]
it says that
um you know but that's why joe manchin
has so much power right and also in t
minus
to 10 months
you've got you know you're going to
assume it's tough it's a tough
assumption you're a democrat but you've
got to assume you're going to lose a
bunch of seats um and your money yeah
like i think just about everyone knows
that the republicans are going to take
the house in
in november unless something freaking
like dramatic changes i have a hard time
imagining what it would be
um so just to throw some math out there
we've probably done this before but
right now democrats have a five seat
majority traditionally the
white the party in power in the white
house loses 10 to 15 seats
um so even if you had like a normal off
cycle you would imagine the republicans
win and oh guess what the republicans
just won in virginia where biden won by
10 points oh guess what like uh joe
biden is tough to say this out loud but
joe biden's is like uh
nearly historically unpopular president
at this stage
um so so you you know you put this stuff
in you'll be like yeah republicans take
the house the real question is do
republicans take the senate
now the senate is tougher because the
map actually lays out better for
democrats uh for for the senate
like the number of
democratic senators who are up for
re-election or in competitive races
is low
relative to the number of republicans
but like you know if you have a big
enough wave
democrats could lose the senate too but
that that's the one that they could be
you know trying to hold uh if you do
play that out though if republicans have
the house and democrats of the senate
what happens from the democratic side
next to nothing you know so yeah
um so you you so you do have this 10
months to try and get something across
the finish line realistically not even
10 months nothing's gonna pass in the
few months prior to re-election uh to
november you probably have like max
um five or six months in the beginning
of next year because
every house member will be out there
trying to you know like get reelected
and oh by the way you're seeing like a
an
uh anomalously high number of democratic
retirements
um
from the house they're like i'm out
yeah so those are older they're like i
don't deal with this anymore oh
some of them aren't old at all like
stephanie murphy out of florida was like
the standard bearer for the moderates
um i think they're called blue dogs uh
problem solvers like she's the head of a
lot of that stuff
so
and she's i don't know like 40s
like uh um wow 50 like maybe i think
she's in her 40s um so she just
announced she was uh not going to run
again
um another person in california just
announced that they're not going to run
again like that so there are a number of
things going on if you are a member of
congress and you're a democrat like this
has been your opportunity to get big
things done and you see the writing on
the wall you're like even if i get
re-elected i'm going to be here in the
minority party and it's going to suck
um so am i really going to sign up for
that
um the the second factor is that right
now the climate in congress is very very
negative and uh spiteful um where
someone told me that
the capitol or the halls of congress
used to be like a shopping mall um even
at like 6 7 p.m because everyone's just
like going around well there's like a
lot of energy a lot of life you like
walking around staffs like um uh you
know doing work
now they they say all the doors are
closed and it's like uh
you know like a ghost mall or uh like
the vibe is really
negative people are just trying to get
out of there staff are very demoralized
um uh part of this was the january 6th
insurrection where uh like it changed
the energy made people not feel safe
um and that there have been a ton of
uh death threats to various members of
congress
much more so than at earlier points
um so if you were
a democratic member of congress you're
like wait why am i like coming back for
this stuff what's my upside down yeah
what what's my upside so you're seeing a
bunch of people retire will that hurt
democrats chances of you know like
limiting their losses yes it will
because you know you'd much rather have
an experienced incumbent with lots of
money running in a seat rather than
someone new yeah so the prospects of
republicans taking the house next year i
think everyone recognizes are very very
high yeah i bet the calculus is pretty
simple it's like you could you can leave
here as the rational sane one or stay on
trying to
plug holes in the bathtub is um
you know that's or you know whatever
your your bathtub analogy where you're
trying to fight a solid problem that
can't be solved and get dragged down
with it yeah it makes sense
yeah so so so those are the the
prospects uh head um you know there's
still a window of opportunity in the
first quarter of next year trying to get
something done
[Music]
speaking of things that need to get done
let's talk about
omicron that's how you say it right it's
an oh it's omicron brother damn it
uh omicron okay omicron is
as a someone who's been in new york um
until recently i'm now in florida um
ripping through the city um but not in
the same way
like prior coveted outbreaks have have
gone where everyone's getting it but
they don't really have symptoms um and
the hospitalization and death rates are
far lower i don't know what your let's
let's talk about i guess your
perspective on what's happening with the
new variant here oh yeah i'm a crown
super contagious
like uh
i mean there were stories where like
people went to a wedding and like half
the people got it and unless you were at
a wedding where like you know people
were
um like making out with each other or
something like you know that that that
seems like awfully
tight yeah yeah it's high right
you know like you're not that freaking
proximate in in a lot of these
environments uh what do i see in the
number it's like that it's like you know
more than five times as contagious
uh it's 73
of new coveted cases right now about to
pass the delta
variant spike in cases where our
seven-day average is 146k uh essentially
impossible to contain its spread contact
tracing
you know ridiculous
the hard um you know one of my proxies
for this stuff zach is what's going on
in the nba i mean have you noticed this
stuff
uh like 70 nba players have gone into
health and safety protocols which means
they got tested and were positive or
were you know
in close proximity to someone who tested
positive but a lot of them were just
tested positive
nhl canceled like basically all their
games from now till christmas
it took a week off essentially so to
your point this is a different
uh
a different type of variant in that it's
super contagious but it's largely pretty
mild particularly if you've been
vaccinated
uh that there was one nba player who
said his main symptom was boredom uh you
know now an nba player who's been
vaccinated as a super athlete is not a
normal specimen but it was still like
like that that is what's happening where
a lot of people are like i know and i
felt like a little cold it felt like
this is especially right you've been
vaccinated
um that so that this is
going to call for a different type of
approach
right i i think for the average person
um that you should do
uh what's reasonable um which in my
opinion would include being vaccinated
and getting a booster and then wearing a
mask and doing some social distancing um
but all of that said you should expect
that you're probably going to get on
vacant
you know
like it's
like this is this is not like a pure
avoidance situation this is uh like you
know uh make yourself
um resistant and resilient uh take some
precautions and then expect to get it um
and then unless you have
pre-existing conditions um you know
expect to be fine like the
hospitalization rate for omicron is very
very low if you've been vaccinated so i
want i've been doing some
research on this and i wanted to
get your opinion but also give some
takes here so um
so our friend friend of the show sagar
and jetty um co-host of breaking points
with crystal ball um
and then um he had an interesting thread
that sparked this conversation then i
talked to a consultant
who we trust because a lot of
consultants we
don't always trust in dc but um
he said
um
he basically i want to preface this by
saying i think i'm vaccinated i'm going
to get my booster i think these are a
good thing donald trump is for the
vaccine and the booster like like
there's a like the date is pretty
enamous that it's keeping you out of the
hospital
um
uh and keeping you from dying
um but it hasn't really what sagar was
saying that hasn't really shown to kind
of stop the spread very much like
there's some evidence on viral load but
it's not it's inconclusive um so the
vaccine have kicked ass at preventing
hospitalizations and death but what he
was saying with sagar was saying they're
not always helping with spreading and
what the solution actually should be is
way better testing and a massive
investment in
at home or easy access to rapid testing
and right now you're seeing this i saw
this at home there are massive lines to
get tested in new york city and dc and
major cities
and in your point andrew with we're in a
country right now where 82
of adults have gotten at least one shot
you've got about three quarters of the
entire population is vaccinated
um
your that last 25
or so percent is not um
the low-hanging fruit's gone they're
probably not getting there right those
are folks that either are allergic to it
or will never do it they don't trust the
government and that's tough and i think
um
the white house put out a statement jeff
zentz or zeitz i'm not sure is i
pronounce his name but he's the white
house covid response coordinator he said
uh he made this basically kind of
villainized those who are unvaccinated
he said we are the quote was we are
intent on not letting omicron omicron
crap omicron disrupt work and school for
the vaccination you are doing what's up
dude so omicron the long no is not right
it's just odd just make an ah omicron
damn it i got it right the first time or
whatever yeah you gotta write the first
time you corrected yourself to the
wrongness all right so his quote was we
are intent on not letting omicron
disrupt work and school for the
vaccinated you have done the right thing
and we will get through this for the
unvaccinated you're looking at a winter
of severe illness and death for
yourselves your families and the
hospitals you may soon overwhelm
and i think
the mandates on vaccines i think are
counterproductive because the folks that
are not getting their vaccine are going
to have the same reaction to
the mandate and i think what they should
do is mandate tests and i'm curious your
thought on this mandate testing so you
don't have to get vaccinated but if
you're not vaccinated and you want a job
companies are requiring you to test
daily
every 12 hours whatever it is and the
government sponsors that so make it a
pain in the ass but you still have the
freedom to do it like this is just our
new normal um like you can wear whatever
pants you want but you have to wear
pants it's kind of the
um the vein of freedom i'm talking about
i don't know what you thought there but
that's there's some companies that are
doing this that are just being like hey
we're going to test you up the wazoo
test you every day yeah i i just met
with a venture capitalist yesterday who
said that he thinks it is unconscionable
that we don't have
uh
tests in every house could send them to
all of you he he said that you know that
unit cost of a test in terms of for the
manufacturer is pennies nickels and most
um you know that there are some
instances where they're charging 30
bucks for something that's costing them
less than 30 cents ah good old
good old us of a and you know so so
there the fact that you have lines
around the block in new york for testing
i don't know about you all but like that
that makes me not particularly want to
stand in that line
i don't understand it i want to walk
near it yeah yeah it's going to be long
you're figuring some of those people
probably haven't probably haven't
tested it it's like a very very covety
line
yeah so clearly
yeah i mean this is common sense so
um so
my friend the vc was like we should just
be sending everyone tests like all the
freaking time um and he's right uh so
you know like that the
um like omicron's a different animal and
our current
setup is not um well designed for it in
in ways because it's
much more contagious uh and
more mild
um and so something like pervasive
at-home testing would make much more
sense than our current setup
[Music]
so i have an employee i'm going to leave
out what organization because i um i
don't want this to become a thing at
that org but i have an employee that
has an allergy to
all of the types of the vaccines can't
get the vacs there's a high risk of
health risks by getting the vaccine
and then have another employee allergic
to vaccines eh i've heard that one
before and i'm kidding i'm kidding um
she's really like let's call it that way
she's oh she's a liberal right um
um
but another employee that's a a cancer
survivor and um
like is is highly susceptible to covid
and is um
you know
like is very very cautious about being
around those who are unvaccinated
and
as an as an organization what do you do
there right because it's tough to punish
either i don't want to punish either of
them for their own health
situations right so we try to do as much
remote as we can but it's not yeah we're
going to promote that thing remotely
yeah and it's
i think for the employee that actually
is allergic to it not as a small subset
but you don't want to punish them um
but you also have to take care of the
the public health right so i think
like the nfl i think did some things
written something's really wrong i think
what they did was
if you're not vaccinated you gotta get
tested way more often but what they did
was that if you
tested positive
if you were unvaccinated you had way
more severe consequences than if you
were vaccinated and that at a certain
point got a little unfair um and a
little ridiculous um aaron rodgers went
on a rant about this i didn't agree with
everything but something some points you
made were accurate um
so i don't know the solution i do think
um
testing would would solve a lot of that
than trying to have this like mandated
vaccination vaccinated society this
might be too tough and cause a lot of
resentment from the populace
i i think it depends on the
circumstances truly it's like you know
like if you're in a job in a role where
you're going to be interfacing heavily
with with other people and the rest of
it i think it's reasonable to say look
like you know we're sticking you in that
environment
that's a good one like if you're going
to do that job you know it's like yeah
you got to be vaccinated and then that's
a company decision rather than a
government decision or can the
government say industry-wide or um
you know i'm saying like that's where
i'm getting at what's where's the rubber
meet the road in terms of the decision
the decision maker
so for the government i mean they're
looking at their own employees and
saying yeah they do government employees
right yeah yeah like you know i'm
looking at you and it's like and and by
the way a lot of these jobs involve like
you know being around a lot of people
like on the regular i think that's
wholly appropriate uh you know like you
said like the gray area comes when
they're they're saying hey private
employers do this do that um and then
you know there are ways that that the
the government can twist people's arms
um in various ways uh you know and that
that is like the tougher call the gray
area where you know i prefer to leave it
to the farms because the the firms have
a better sense of what's going on with
with their employees but that i mean
that's that we do do this we've done it
for measles and mumps and polio and
other things so
um
this stuff's delicate i think sagar made
some really good points i thought um
um
you know the consultant i was being made
some good points about the this was a
this was a conscious decision by the buy
administration to basically go to war
with the anti or the the unvaccinated um
but that said like one of the things
that's crazy is a lot of the folks
in the military like military vaccine
vaccinated numbers went up pretty um
pretty like it's your turn hundreds and
hundreds of thousands so i mean so here
here's part like here the things that
are tough man it's like if you leave
people to their own devices a lot of
people are not going to get vaccinated
by and large population wide it's a good
thing to be vaccinated like and so if
you're the government uh you know like
what are you going to do it's like
you're going to encourage everyone to
get vaccinated go all in
yeah yeah and so what's funny is i get
asked about uh you know my my take on
this in different ways and it's like you
have a very different take depending
upon what seat you're in if i was the
head of the government i'd be like we
got to do everything in our power to get
everyone vaccinated
you know
like
genuinely this is like well like
population wide it like makes sense and
like let's freaking do it um you know
now if you're not in that seat then you
know you have a different perspective
because you understand that people are
in different situations and it's more
nuanced and like you know like the rest
of it that makes a lot of sense how dare
you have nuance andrew um
there's no room for that in my 140k but
i will say uh you know i've been
vaccinated like uh you know i think
everyone should get vaccinated and if i
was the head of the government i'd be
pushing everyone to get vaccinated
[Music]
so we have catalogued dysfunction in dc
nothing new but very dispiriting talked
about how omicron wildly contagious and
you know it should take precautions but
probably going to get it so we're trying
now to to end on uplifting notes
here on the ford podcast and i'm going
to make a case
that
is i hope very upbeat and positive which
is that the new spider-man movie
is something we should be excited about
on a couple of levels no spoilers right
no spoilers no spoilers so number one
this movie did gangbusters business uh
it is the second biggest opening of all
time it beat out avengers infinity war
it's right behind end game and just goes
to show that if you have
a compelling offering and people will
still come out in droves to go to a real
life in person movie theater spend some
of their hard earned money put their
butt in that seat and watch what i will
say i saw this movie it is a very very
uh excellent movie
and so number one there there is still
hope for real life in person experiences
uh like movie theaters that's good i
think they did a really good job
marketing it too between
the lead characters dating and the the
roll out i think they let a lot of you
mean that pretend romance no i'm kidding
it seems real so it might be fake if
it's fake i bought it hook line and
sinker baby oh it seems real that seems
real you know
one of the most uplifting
pieces of content on the internet if you
haven't seen it you should go to see it
right now
is the lim lip sync battle between tom
holland and zendaya the singing in the
rain uh video zach do you know what i'm
talking about i do and tom holland
was showed to me that how talented he
was without you know a side of him i
hadn't seen before at least when i first
watched it if you don't know what andrew
yang is talking about right now
just go to youtube and google singing in
the rain tom holland and you will be
glad you did because it's the most
delightful four minutes of content and
so you see future boyfriend and
girlfriend tom holland and zendaya in a
lip sync battle they're both phenomenal
but tom holland kind of next levels this
thing he does something
that
uh in a way it kind of sets such a high
water mark for lip sync battle that
there's no place to go but but down you
know what i mean like you already kind
of like like
defined the form and then everyone else
is a panel limitation anyway
so
check that out that that that'll be a
bit of uplift for sure um but the second
reason why i think that this movie is
such an exciting marker for the future
is that it does things that no one
thought were possible
and that's kind of what we need in
american life today i'm going to just
throw you know a couple parallels it's
like you have this dysfunctional duopoly
and it's like oh we're trudging along
and everyone's sad and then andrew yang
comes along was like hey let's start a
new party the forward party and let's by
the way try and make it so that new
parties can emerge that aren't just us
like you know anyone who wants like a
vibrant system and then people like oh
it's not possible it can't be done
there is stuff that goes on in this
movie that you would legitimately say
like this should not cannot be possible
like
things that
some
uh
fan fiction writer even they would be
like there's no way like like that this
thing just doesn't seem and and they did
it in like a major major tent poll
like uh you know what like at this point
uh maybe like a franchise defining tent
pole um they just pushed so many
boundaries they integrated different uh
worlds and universes
um and so right now you have this
political universe that is so stayed
and insular and it's like beltway this
and like you know like uh cable news
that and then there's this entire world
outside of it that we need to kind of
combine and integrate with the world of
politics it's happening in media you can
sense it there's some like alternative
media voices that are just rising in
popularity because people are so tired
of the nonsense and the bs
um and so you can imagine what like a
normal
uh spider-man movie would would be like
and now it would just seem like such a
crushing disappointment compared to what
this what they did with this movie like
so
it's it's kind of funny to say but like
i feel like
this movie gives you like a sense of
what's actually possible if for example
a couple of major movie studios let's
call them sony and marvel got together
combined all their ip took like you know
20 years of movie history and like smash
them all together if if sony and marvel
can do it maybe
you know the american people can do it
too maybe like ford and
libertarians and
socialists and democrats and republicans
and independents can all make it happen
wow that's like
frankly not that they need it because it
looks like they're killing it but that's
a pretty ringing endorsement for a movie
andrew um from you so
um i was going to see it this week maybe
i'll go tonight maybe i'm not like you
know get out my chair but i didn't like
freaking send us your review man you can
text me because that that movie was like
there were a number of times watching
the movie i was like i can't believe i'm
seeing this
stuff that you would imagine in a dream
and then like they invested you know
whatever like tens hundreds of millions
of dollars in it
i love it man and i like it we're ending
this on uplifting things i'm gonna
rattle off a couple too uh we have an
hiv vaccine in the works that's looking
really positive and it's the same mrna
technology used in the covidvax
that
seems to be working it's not official
yet but it's in we're in human trials at
this point which is super exciting
there's a company called air company
which you know can debate the name that
makes alcohol out of air have you seen
this
no but i like it i would and i would
experience but it's crazy that they're
creating a product that doesn't that's
like
extremely good for the environment to
produce or no no cost to the environment
um now i've not tried this i need to buy
it um to test it out and maybe it's mad
expensive i'm not sure but i like the
trend of companies like that making
money
selling a product people need with
basically no like carbon neutral
look at you promoting air alcohol you
don't know about it and you haven't
done about it but it's still cool
it's worth trying right it sounds cool
forward sponsored by air alcohol air
company air company if you're listening
to this we would love a sponsorship um
and the other one i'll leave you with is
this stuff just fascinates me
there is a professor eduardo fernandez
who the director of neuroengineering at
the university of miguel hernandez in
spain
who
has gotten us one step closer to helping
blind people see he's basically created
this like
i don't want to call it a bionic eye
because that's too far in but basically
instead of trying to fabricate
yeah i guess so instead of recreating
the eye though it's like plugging into
your nerves and then there's a there's a
yeah there's a camera that's like
sending but it's using the brain signals
that we normally get from our eye
um
to help your brain interpret what's
going on out in the world um and it's
it's in a woman's it's been implanted in
a woman's head and she's like
had like pretty good success
and then the first thing she does the
first thing she does is she goes to a
police station
leans into the desk and says
i'll be back
and then walks out and then crash the
car through the front maybe
maybe
which is this terminator that's that's
that's one brother
there's been way too many terminator
movies they've tried it's like all these
future movies you see people get healed
real quickly and i just don't think
we've gotten there yet um but i think
we're we're poised to take a leap um
whether it's their stuff in spinal cord
injuries or bionic eyes or bionic limbs
or slowing and reversing brain aging man
i mean that's like the main one like uh
that my guy is working on at mit
uh you know and and you should know
andrew yang is not one of those
uh like people who's like we're gonna
live forever we're doing all the stuff
it's like you know like i like i'm i'm
not that guy
but
but but but if we can
uh
slow down
uh deterioration and that leads to
alzheimer's the rest of it i mean that
that's gonna just save save lives and
like improve people's quality of life in
like an enormous way you know the black
mirror episode where they upload their
consciousness into uh like a different
reality like there's one i think it's
the 80s one
are you in favor of that or is that too
much too far in terms of living i think
if we did it it would just be you know
i'd be dead and then there'd be like
some simulated version of my
consciousness yucking it up in like some
software interface like does that do
anything for
for me it's like i don't know my loved
ones if they want to hang out with a
simulation of me maybe
um but uh yeah it's like as you can tell
i'm not that into it
[Laughter]
yeah i'm not a thriller living forever
either i think the the finite aspect of
life makes it
better um
as much as it makes it harder
i'm 46 i'm turning 47. they're like
different life stages that occurred like
different times i mean like the things
i'm into now so different than you know
10 years ago or 15 years ago or the rest
of i mean obviously i'm still seeing the
same movies so i mean that stays the
same but like spider-man just change
just like you're you know like the way
you want to relax and enjoy yourself
yeah it's like you know like that
maturation it's generally a good thing i
i will say too
though that like that there is something
i i i looked at the happiness curves of
uh men this will make you happy zack but
apparently like men tend to get more
chilled out over time
middle-aged and like older guys this
will be good news for all the dudes
listening to this but like apparently we
we we do get more content relaxed as we
get older there's like an intensity
um
to the you know to
being young that ends up kind of
moderating over time good times good
times i think that's a good thing i
think being a monogamous relationship
has helped me with that um
you know what do they say you hear that
lady zach might be off the market oh
hear that monogamous
did he just out himself as being a
boyfriend
there goes half of our female listener
base there they go
they weren't here for me
i think most people are for you man i'm
here for color commentary um
yeah
you know i i think there's like a time
and a place and like you know it
includes like aging um uh you know aging
you know we want to stay healthy and
whatnot and vital and
productive um and positive but you know
that there is a
there's like a series of uh stages that
that you know i think are part of life
and on that happy note happy holidays
this is gonna come out and christmas eve
eve i hope that everyone is having a
wonderful holiday
uh with loved ones like zack zack's
visiting his family uh hug
your your mom your family members your
friends treat yourself well we have a
bit of a break 2022 is going to be the
year uh of of some stuff
i i think it's gonna be better than this
year
so yeah just try and get like a true
rest relax treat yourself well take a
walk
you know commune with nature a little
bit and we'll all be back at it in no
time happy holidays everybody
[Music]
you